greffé de la moelle osseuse en octobre
2018 à la suite d'une leucémie damien
berthet est l'un des douze coureurs
transplantés qui va participer à la
course du coeur organisé par
l'association transforme une association
qui promeut le sport chez les personnes
greffées la course solidaire regroupera
160 personnes 750 km de course à pied en
fin de course de vélo et de roller en
relève on a une première étape en ile de
france
et ensuite
donc ça c'est sur quatre jours et quatre
nuits pour terminer ensuite à bourg
saint maurice le dimanche midi et on
célèbre la montée à des harkis les 15
points 4 km et lille mais des dénivelés
sont nés deux personnes au fait de la
moelle est
majoritairement c'est donc des greffes
de foie et des greffes de rein on a
entre 29 et 78 une course à un objectif
sensibiliser le grand public au don
d'organes et de tissus en france donc il
ya soixante trois mille personnes qui
sont à greffer
25 ou 27 mai qui sont en attente de
greffe et dans mon cas précis le don de
moelle osseuse est un don du vivant donc
j'ai envie de faire partager tout le
monde peut s'inscrire
il suffit d'aller dans un fr avoir moins
de 35 ans et s'inscrire sur le registre
international des dons de moelle osseuse
courir pour montrer que l'activité
sportive est possible suite à une
transplantation une évidence pour ce
coureur qui a commencé à courir il y a
dix ans dans le cas d'un d'une greffe ou
dans le cas d'un cancer comme le mien en
fait le
l'activité sportive donc permettre aux
greffons de bien s'implanter permet de
garder un bon style de vie et de réduire
en fait de 40 % le risque de rechute par
exemple pour moi pour mon cancer quand
on était enfermé pendant quatre semaines
4 x 4 semaines dans les chambres
stériles qu'on savait pas si on allait
ressortir la première fois c'est en en
profitant pour fil de la vie la course
du coeur passera par les yvelines dans
la nuit du 23 au 24 mars elle traversera
200 communes françaises durant son
parcours